the majority of the teeth problems that
we have in this country have to do with
sugar I thought is the into water the
floor mat on the water now fluoride in
the water that that fluoride in the
water thing is so sketchy have you ever
looked into whether or not fluoride
should be in the water well there I know
the Russian I know that in 50s Colorado
had a high concentration of fluoride in
its water and apparently the get my
poker out I'm going to spoke at the at
the board I think it came out of
Colorado where there was high
concentrations of fluoride in the water
and then what happened was they go well
there's a cluster of people who are not
getting cavities and so apparently
fluoride is effective at keeping
cavities in bay and I grew up overseas
my teeth the [ __ ] I had [ __ ] sweet
sugar
what not so much overseas but I I
definitely didn't brush my teeth a lot
and I didn't have fluoride well let's
let's Google whether or not there's
evidence that fluoride is good for tooth
decay do you think it's all marketing
hype from crest I don't know man I've
read too many hippy articles the problem
is the hippy or herpes refused you
because it'll say like natural news
letter the brush with like colons you
don't know Matt because there's people
that get like all homeopathic on you and
you're like okay is this guy right like
I'm reading I'm gonna go through 5,000
words here and my Izzy writer is this
horse [ __ ] am I gonna okay now I gotta
look up the actual studies okay not
gonna read this three times cuz I'm
stupid
yeah and I can't figure out how you
looking for it no evidence that
fluoridated water causes cavities
reduces cavities rather but that's from
dr. Mercola now that's a 1 now i've
posted articles from Mercola calm if
people go oh that guy's amazing and then
other people go that guy's a fraud it's
tough to figure out I've read some stuff
on dr. McCulloh well you read just like
the same kind of stuff and he seems to
be pretty like he's a doctor but that
doesn't mean he's an expert on to the
gay or on looking at the hard evidence
behind
the American Dental Association Florida
and water a feeling they must have some
seven years of scientific research you
guys are lucky yet he's not here he's on
an evolution kick now more than 70 years
of scientific research has consistently
shown that an optimal level of fluoride
in community water is safe and effective
in preventing tooth decay safe is a
scary word why why would you be worried
about that by at least 25% of all
children adults simply by drinking water
Americans can benefit from fluorides
cavity protection within our homework of
school Centers for Disease Control
Control and Prevention named community
water fluoridation one obtain ten great
public health achievements of the 20th
century
okay now go to the one that says there's
no evidence because I got out who the
[ __ ] is right here well I would suggest
that it's been a long time I mean
remember what the food pyramid used to
look like cavities in a review of every
fluoridation study they could find it
was the Cochran I don't know if the
Cochran talking I know you guys like to
talk over each other trying to that's
what we do bro the view of every
fluoridation study they could find only
three studies since 1975 looked the
effectiveness of water fluoridation at
reducing tooth decay among the general
population and had high enough quality
to be included the studies found
fluoridation does not reduce cavities to
a statistically significant degree in
permanent teeth in the two studies since
1975 that examined the effectiveness of
fluoridation and reduce reducing
cavities in baby teeth no significant
reduction was noted there either you
know what I'm thinking right now read
you know what's going on in my head
what's behind my head right now as I go
I'm thinking this is why Google is not a
place to go for information to be
discerning you have to if - this is why
peer-reviewed papers are so important
this is why it's like really valuable
journalists scientific journalists
especially are important that's right
that's exact we don't know who's right
we just said something that people going
what so I feel like we have to get to
the bottom of this although we a man the
three of us you guys know anything you
can kind of look at general trends like
I said to my analyst metal in my teeth
right and my dentist because you know
leaks mercury and he said I know I was
on the I was on that study panel and if
you look at the massive the massive
number of people that have metal in
their mouth you'd have you would be able
to draw some pretty broad-based
conclusions because you have such a huge
human ya pool and they just haven't they
looked at the don't do a lot of
comprehensive studies that's the same
dentists who said your teeth are
straight no this is a different one and
I'm wearing my Invisalign so I'd
appreciate if you wouldn't be my teeth
is there to be amazing weird at night
I'm wearing them right now and you can
tell never